Steven, je dois vous interrompre,
car nous venons d'apprendre à l'instant,
par l'agence de presse britannique,
que Diana, princesse de Galles,
est décédée.
Dimanche 31 août 1997.
La nouvelle brutale se propage
dans le monde entier.
Madame, Monsieur, Bonjour,
la princesse de Galles, Lady Di
est morte cette nuit à Paris,
dans un accident de voiture.
Elle était au mauvais endroit,
au mauvais moment,
avec les mauvaises personnes.
La Mercedes noire où Diana avait pris
place avec son compagnon du moment,
le milliardaire égyptien Dodi Al-Fayed,
leur garde du corps et leur chauffeur,
a heurté de plein fouet le 13ᵉ pilier
du tunnel du pont de l'Alma.
À 0h25 exactement.
Dans le tunnel, j'entends une double
explosion comme ça.
Et en contrebas, je vois la Mercedes
en sens inverse.
Phares allumés.
3h30 plus tard, on doit
constater le décès de Diana,
épouse divorcée du prince de Galles,
des suites de ses blessures.
L'angleterre a perdu son sourire.
Sa princesse s'est éteinte ce matin à
l'hôpital parisien de la Pitié-Salpêtrière.
C'était impossible de ne pas être ému.
C'était un moment extraordinairement
difficile et émouvant.
Sans conteste.
C'est une des femmes les plus célèbres,
les plus adulées du monde
qui vient de disparaître.
L'événement est considérable
à tout niveau,
y compris politique et diplomatique.
L'émotion est planétaire
et tout de suite,
on cherche à en savoir davantage.
À qui appartenait la berline ?
Qui la conduisait ?
Roulait-elle vite ? Oui.
Très vite ? Oui.
Mais alors pourquoi ?
D'où venait-elle ?
Vers où fonçait-elle ainsi ?
Y a-t-il seulement eu des témoins ?
Et s'il ne s'agissait
pas vraiment d'un accident ?
Très vite, la rumeur enfle.
En quelques heures, ce qui se dessine,
c'est une grande énigme.
L'énigme du siècle.
Ainsi donc, Lady Di est morte à l'issue de
16 ans d'une histoire hyper médiatisée.
une histoire qui avait commencé
à la façon d'un conte de fées.
En ce 29 juillet 1981,
plus de 750 millions de téléspectateurs
à travers le monde,
ont les yeux rivés sur Londres,
Une Londres emplie de couleurs
et de petits drapeaux.
Ils suivent plus ou moins ébloui de la
cathédrale Saint-Paul au palais de Buckingham,
les épisodes solennels d'un
mariage idéal en apparence.
L'union tardive
du prince Charles, 32 ans,
Héritier de la couronne d'Angleterre,
et de la jeune naïve, timide et délicieuse
Lady Diana Spencer, 19 ans.
Les envoyés spéciaux n'en finissent pas de
commenter la robe, le voile, le diadème.
Ils s'émeuvent comme tout le monde,
du beau regard de biche apeuré,
qu'exhibe la toute nouvelle princesse.
Et ce jour là, nombreux sont les hommes qui,
à travers le monde,
se sentent un peu amoureux de Lady Di.
Problème, ce n'est pas le cas
du principal intéressé.
Je suis surpris qu'elle ait été
assez courageuse pour me choisir !
- Et, j'imagine, amoureux ?
- Bien sûr !
Tout dépend de
ce qu'on entend par amoureux,
C'est une question d'interprétation,
Regardez le visage de Diana
pendant cette interview.
Elle le regarde, perplexe,
comme si elle voulait dire :
"Tu ne sais pas ce que c'est que l'amour ?
Moi je le sais. Pourquoi pas toi ?"
Paul Burrell a été le majordome de la
princesse pendant dix ans.
Il est devenu au fil du temps
un confidents précieux.
Vous savez, le prince Charles a été
élevé dans un monde très différent.
Où l'amour n'est pas exprimé de la même manière.
Ils ne sont pas comme nous.
La famille royale est totalement différente.
Ce sont presque des aliène
d'une autre planète.
Promettez-vous de l'aimer,
de la chérir,
de l'honorer dans la santé et la maladie,
et, renonçant à toute autre,
de lui rester toujours fidèle,
tout au long de votre vie.
Je le veux.
Si Diana fait un mariage d'amour,
le prince Charles, lui, n'a consenti
qu'à un mariage de raison.
C'est sa grand-mère, la reine mère
Elizabeth, veuve du roi George VI,
qui a plus ou moins arrangé l'union
de son petit fils aîné,
avec cette jeune fille de très bonne famille,
issue d'une lignée qu'elle connaît bien,
les Spencer.
Pourtant, si Diana connait depuis toujours
la famille royale et son entourage,
elle ne maîtrise pas les codes
complexes de Buckingham.
Croyant épouser le prince charmant,
elle va se découvrir assez vite la
victime d'un arrangement d'état,
et la prisonnière de charges officielles
à la limite du supportable.
Depuis qu'on connaît l'identité
de la jeune femme,
elle est harcelée par les photographes.
Je ne dirais rien, désolée.
C'est le début d'une traque qui s'interrompera
brutalement dans 17 ans.
La princesse acquiert rapidement une
popularité qu'on n'aurait pas soupçonné.
La timide jeune fille se métamorphose
au fil des mois.
Attitude, tenue,
à chaque déplacement, les regards
sont tournés vers elle.
Une popularité qui fait même
de l'ombre à son propre époux.
Avril 1983.
Quand la foule a salué
l'arrivée de la princesse,
il a été parfaitement heureux
de prendre la seconde place.
Je suis arrivé à la conclusion qu'il aurait
été plus facile d'avoir deux femmes,
afin de couvrir les deux côtés de la rue,
J'aurais pu ainsi marcher au centre,
en dirigeant les opérations.
La romance aidant, les premières années peuvent
donner l'impression d'une certaine harmonie.
Le 21 juin 1982,
les apparences sont sauves
à la naissance de William.
Mais ces images de conte de fées,
cachent une réalité de moins en moins
supportable pour la jeune femme,
notamment lors de la naissance
du deuxième enfant, Harry.
15 septembre 1984.
La princesse m'a raconté
que le jour où Harry est né,
Charles est venu à l'hôpital
pour voir son nouveau bébé.
Il a dit : "Un autre garçon,
j'ai accompli mon devoir.
Maintenant, j'ai un héritier ainsi
qu'un autre de rechange.
Je vais sortir ce soir.
Je vais à l'opéra avec Camilla."
Diana m'a dit : "La nuit où Harry est né,
je me suis endormie en pleurant,
sachant que mon mariage était fini."
Ainsi le prince héritier cache-t-il à peine sa
liaison avec celle qu'il aime depuis toujours,
Camilla Parker Bowles.
Camilla a toujours été là,
dans les coulisses.
Diana l'a toujours su, mais elle pensait
qu'elle pouvait amener Charles à l'aimer.
Elle pensait qu'être mariée avec Charles
et avoir ses enfants ferait toute la différence.
Mais ça n'a rien changé pour Charles.
Il n'a toujours aimé que Camilla.
Pourquoi ne l'a-t-il pas épousé ?
Parce qu'elle ne correspondait pas aux
exigences de la famille royale.
Elle s'est d'ailleurs mariée avec
un officier des horse guards.
Diana découvre peu à peu cette situation,
et le sentiment se développe
en elle de n'avoir été,
de n'être qu'un jouet
au sein de la famille royale.
Non content de la délaisser,
son époux se fait volontiers méprisant.
Elle avait une magnifique robe en tissu
écossais faite pour un voyage,
et il lui a dit :
"Tu ressembles à une hôtesse
de l'air écossaise."
Il la dénigrait complètement.
Les mots peuvent parfois être
plus cruels que les gestes seuls.
Je n'ai jamais vu Charles faire
du mal physiquement à Diana,
mais je l'ai vu lui
en faire psychologiquement.
Il lui disait qu'elle était trop grosse
puis qu'elle était trop maigre,
ce qui la minait constamment et l'a rendu
boulimique et anorexique.
Elle était à bout de nerf.
Mais ni Charles ni la famille royale
ne prêteront suffisamment l'oreille,
pour entendre ses signaux d'alerte.
J'étais à Sandingan quand Diana
s'est jeté dans les escaliers.
Personne ne l'écoutait.
Elle devait faire des choses dramatiques
pour attirer l'attention,
et qu'on écoute ce qu'elle avait à dire.
Au quotidien, la relation entre
Charles et Diana devient catastrophique.
Diana elle-même va finir
par prendre des amants,
mais il faut maintenir l'illusion.
4 octobre 1985.
La famille accueille une équipe de tournage à
Kensington Palace,
la résidence officielle du couple.
Il s'agit de rassurer l'opinion
qui commence à s'interroger.
Le jeu d'acteur est parfait.
J'imagine que la plupart des maris
et femmes ont souvent des disputes.
Mais pas nous !
Mais parfois il nous arrive...
Non, pas nous.
Tous deux ont beau jouer le jeu,
leur couple est une mascarade.
À partir de 1987, Charles et Diana
ne partageront plus la même suite,
lors des voyages officiels.
Mais ils continuent
à accomplir leur devoir.
Jusqu'en 1992, où le fragile
équilibre vole en éclats.
10 février,
le couple princier arrive en Inde.
Mais c'est seule devant le Taj Mahal,
monument de l'amour,
que Diana se fait photographier.
Le symbole est fort.
Ces images vont faire le tour du monde.
7 juin 1992.
Moins de trois mois plus tard,
un livre scelle la fin de cette union.
Le journaliste Andrew Morton y révèle au
grand public la vérité quant au calvaire,
quotidien de la future reine d'Angleterre.
Charles ne m'écoutait pas,
alors j'ai pris son canif,
et je me suis entaillé la poitrine
et les cuisses.
Il y avait beaucoup de sang.
Ça ne l'a pas fait réagir pour autant.
Les membres de la famille royale était
extrêmement en colère,
surtout quand ils se sont rendus compte
que Diana avait contribué au livre.
C'était du jamais vu.
Les princesses royales et encore
plus la future reine d'Angleterre,
ne doivent pas parler aux médias.
C'est une règle qui vient d'en haut,
de la reine.
Le livre très attendu d'Andrew Morton sur le
mariage duprince et de la princesse de Galles,
est enfin arrivé dans les rayons.
À midi, certaines librairies avaient
déjà épuisé tout leur stock.
L'éditeur a commandé une deuxième impression
pour faire face à la demande.
Comme toujours,
il faut maintenir les apparences.
Pensant pouvoir encore
arranger la situation,
la reine reste stoïque.
Mais un scandale en chasse un autre.
Ce sont d'abord des enregistrements de
conversations téléphoniques ambiguës,
entre Diana et l'un de ses proches amis,
que révèle la presse.
Puis l'existence de sa relation
passée avec James Hewitt,
le professeur d'équitation
de ses enfants.
Quelques semaines plus tard,
c'est au tour du Camillagate,
un enregistrement de huit minutes,
des échanges intimes entre Charles et Camilla
est rendu publiques par la presse people.
Evidemment, cette succession de scandales,
déplaît fortement à Buckingham Palace,
à la reine en particulier.
Diana, la jeune femme qu'elle croyait
docile est désormais bien gênante.
Même certains de ses combats
caritatifs incommode la souveraine.
En avril 1987, alors que Diana
était la première personnalité,
à s'engager publiquement en serrant
la main d'un malade du sida,
la reine lui avait recommandé de choisir
des causes plus plaisantes.
C'est une grande première,
aucun membre de la famille royale
n'a effectué de voyage officiel,
en Corée du Sud jusqu'à maintenant.
2 novembre 1992, Charles et Diana,
sous les objectifs avides
de centaines de photographes,
effectuent ce qui sera leur
dernier voyage officiel ensemble.
Pour le couple royal, c'est une occasion
de redorer l'image écornée de son mariage.
Bien que la princesse n'affiche un air
bien sombre après un voyage aussi long.
Mais la longueur du voyage
n'est pas le fond du problème.
La princesse ne joue
même plus la comédie.
Elle arbore un visage fermé,
des yeux tristes,
un air constamment ennuyé
qui ne trompe personne.
La parole est au Premier ministre.
9 décembre 1992.
La séparation est officielle.
C'est le Premier ministre John Major
qui l'annonce aux députés.
Il est annoncé par Buckingham Palace
qu'avec regret,
le prince et la princesse de Galles
ont décidé de se séparer.
Sa Majesté et Son Altesse Royale espèrent
notamment que les intrusions,
dans la vie privée du prince
et de la princesse vont maintenant cesser.
Pour Diana,
c'est une nouvelle ère qui s'ouvre,
celle d'une vie libérée sur laquelle
elle compte bien reprendre le contrôle.
Quand la princesse
s'est séparée du prince Charles,
Elle m'a dit qu'on allait commencer
à voyager à travers le monde.
On avait une grande carte du monde
et une boîte pleine de punaises rouges,
et elle a commencé à piquer
la carte avec ses punaises,
aux endroits où elle devait
voyager et aider les gens.
Elle m'a dit : "Je vais devenir
une ambassadrice pour le monde.
J'irai là où on a besoin de moi."
C'était sa nouvelle vie.
Être là où elle voulait être.
Aller là où elle voulait aller.
Et personne ne pourrait l'en empêcher.
Après leur séparation, Charles et Diana
se livrent un combat sans merci,
par médias interposés.
En juin 94, le prince franchit le pas.
Il reconnaît devant 10 millions de
téléspectateurs qu'il a été infidèle.
L'année suivante, Diana monte d'un cran.
Elle évoque longuement les problèmes de son
mariage dans la célèbre émission Panorama,
sur la BBC.
Devant 15 millions de téléspectateurs,
elle va même plus loin.
Elle met en cause la famille royale,
et s'interroge sur la capacité
de Charles à régner.
Du jamais vu en Grande-Bretagne.
Il est temps de mettre
un terme à l'escalade.
Le 28 août 1996,
Charles et Diana divorcent.
Vous mesurez ce que cela veut dire à la cour
d'Angleterre. Charles est tout de même le futur roi,
Le futur chef de l'Eglise anglicane.
Pour Diana, à 35 ans,
le moment est venu de profiter
pleinement de sa liberté nouvelle.
Une liberté qui va lui coûter cher.
13 janvier 1997.
C'est un immense privilège pour moi
d'avoir été invitée ici, en Angola,
pour soutenir la Croix Rouge,
et sa campagne pour bannir, une fois
pour toutes, toutes les mines antipersonnel.
La princesse épanouie,
libérée du carcan royal,
tout en demeurant maître
dans l'art de fasciner les médias,
se lance à corps perdu dans
les combats caritatifs,
qui lui tiennent le plus à cœur.
On l'avait vu soutenir les malades du sida.
Diana s'engage à présent
dans une croisade autrement politique,
celle du combat contre
les mines antipersonnel.
Je me rappelle d'un moment à l'hôpital où
elle a rendu visite à une petite fille,
couchée dans un lit.
On voyait bien qu'elle
n'en avait plus pour très longtemps.
Diana s'est assise.
Elle lui a tenu la main
et la petite fille s'est mise à sourire.
Après le départ de la princesse,
la petite fille a demandé :
"Est-ce que c'est un ange
qui est venu me voir ?"
Et pour bien montrer
que rien ne l'intimide,
celle qui est toujours officiellement
Princesse de Galles,
devient ambassadrice pour le Halo Trust.
Organisation, la plus radicale dans l'opposition
à l'emploi des mines antipersonnel.
De quoi à exaspérer les industriels
de l'armement, entre autres,
mais aussi le gouvernement britannique.
Avez vous été surprise par le scandale politique
qui a engendré votre visite en Angola ?
Je trouve ceci sans importance,
car je ne suis pas une figure politique.
Je suis une figure humanitaire,
je l'ai toujours été et je le serai toujours.
Qu'importe à Diana,
à présent, elle est libre.
Il faut que tout le monde
en ait bien conscience.
C'est à peine croyable,
toutes ces années où elle était
mariée au Prince de Galles,
elle n'avait pas d'argent.
Elle n'avait rien qui lui appartenait.
Elle n'avait que ce qu'il
voulait bien lui donner.
Le jour où le divorce a été prononcé,
elle est entrée avec un morceau de papier
dans les mains et elle a dit :
"Maintenant,
je suis une femme indépendante."
3 juin 1997,
comme pour faire peau neuve,
elle organise chez Christie's,
la vente caritative de 79 de
ses anciennes robes d'Altesse Royale.
79 robe de ce qui sera désormais
son ancienne vie.
85 000, 100 000...
Je savais qu'elle allait le dire.
200 000 !
11 juillet 1997,
on la découvre en vacances
à Saint-Tropez,
comme pourrait l'être une star de cinéma,
dans le somptueux domaine de Mohamed Al-Fayed,
un milliardaire égyptien.
Elle était enthousiaste parce qu'elle
pouvait emmener William et Harry avec elle.
La princesse n'avait ses fils seule que deux
fois par an pour des petites vacances.
Et c'était l'occasion parfaite d'être
avec eux dans un environnement sûr.
Pour accueillir comme il se doit
la princesse et ses enfants,
Mohamed Al-Fayed n'a pas
lésiné sur les moyens.
Il a pour l'occasion acheté
un yacht somptueux, le Jonikal.
Incroyable mélange des genres,
désapprouvés par la reine.
Car Mohamed Al-Fayed,
en dépit de ses efforts,
n'a jamais réussi à se faire accepter
par ce que l'on appelle l'establishment.
Il est pourtant propriétaire
du grand magasin londonien Harrods,
une véritable institution
en Grande-Bretagne,
longtemps fournisseur officiel
de la famille royale.
Mais l'Angleterre ne lui
a jamais fait l'honneur,
de lui accorder
la nationalité britannique,
car il est soupçonné d'avoir
utilisé des fonds mal acquis,
pour racheter Harrods.
Diana va-t-elle au moins se cacher
des photographes électrisés,
par la présence sur la Côte d'Azur
des deux jeunes princes ?
Pas vraiment.
Pas du tout.
La princesse m'a dit qu'elle
allait faire une blague à la presse.
Elle m'a dit :
"Regardez les photos dans les magazines,
je vais porter le même maillot de bain
tous les jours pendant mes vacances.
Ils auront tout le temps la même photo."
C'était plutôt malin en fait.
La princesse de Galles s'arrange
pour se faire voir des photographes,
heureuse, insouciante et belle.
Ils ont besoin d'elle.
Elle a besoin d'eux.
Il est vrai qu'au même moment,
à Londres,
le prince Charles organise une réception,
pour les 50 ans de sa maîtresse
de toujours, Camilla.
La guerre des images continue.
Quelques jours après
l'arrivée de la princesse,
le fils de Mohamed Al-Fayed
les rejoint sur le yacht.
On le surnomme Dodi.
Il a six ans de plus que Diana.
Il est producteur de films
à ses heures perdues.
C'est surtout un homme
à la réputation de Don Juan.
Diana et Dodi, s'étaient déjà
croisé au fil des années,
comme ici en 1988,
lors d'un match de polo.
Ils ne se saluaient encore que
d'une cordiale poignée de main.
À peine quelques jours suffisent
pour que la rumeur d'une romance,
entre les deux personnalités
enflamme la presse people.
Est-ce le début d'une relation sérieuse ?
Ou ne serait-ce qu'une petite vengeance
orchestrée par Diana elle-même ?
Car il se murmure que la princesse cherche
avant tout à rendre jaloux un autre homme,
un certain Hasnat Kahn,
médecin pakistanais avec lequel elle
a eu une relation discrète pendant deux ans,
et qui vient de la quitter.
La princesse Diana vient d'arriver en Bosnie
pour faire campagne jusqu'à dimanche,
contre les mines antipersonnel.
8 août 1997,
la princesse Diana est sous le feu
de l'actualité, de toutes les actualités.
En effet, parenthèse,
dans son début de romance,
elle se rend en Bosnie.
Le but : Dénoncer encore, toujours
l'utilisation des mines antipersonnel.
Mais ce ne sont pas franchement les photos
de Diana en Bosnie qui intéressent les paparazzis.
Pour eux, il y a beaucoup plus d'argent
à se faire en prenant,
les photos croustillantes
de ces vacances qu'on dit amoureuses.
3 millions de francs,
c'est à ce prix que s'arrachera
la photo qui va faire le tour du monde.
Un scoop planétaire.
Pour la première fois depuis Charles,
Diana est photographiée
dans les bras d'un homme.
The Kiss, le baiser, s'affiche en une
du Sunday Mirror le 10 août.
C'était une manipulation.
C'était fabriqué de toutes pièces
cette photo du baiser sur le bateau.
Elle savait qu'elle allait être prise.
Bien sur qu'elle le savait.
Elle m'a demandé après :
"Est-ce que Hasnat a vu la photo ?"
J'ai répondu :
"Qu'est-ce que Hasnat à avoir là dedans ?"
Elle a insisté :
"Est-ce qu'il a vu la photo ?"
"Oui, c'est en une de tous les journaux."
"Bien." M'a-t-elle répondu.
A Buckingham, on cherche
à ménager la reine Elizabeth.
La photo n'apparaît même pas dans la revue de
presse quotidienne transmise à la souveraine.
Il n'empêche, le mal est fait.
Ce qui exaspère la reine, c'est le
comportement irrationnel de Diana,
et son manque de discrétion.
La princesse de Galles
n'en fait qu'à sa tête,
comme si elle cherchait
à prendre une revanche.
Certes, elle avait caché sa
relation amoureuse de deux ans,
avec Hasnat Khan mais avec Dodi Al-Fayed,
elle est beaucoup moins prudente.
Si elle se concrétisait, cette aventure
aurait de quoi inquiéter la couronne.
Imaginez un peu la situation,
la mère du futur roi d'Angleterre
avec un play boy musulman,
dont la famille est soupçonnée d'avoir trempé
dans des trafics pas toujours nets.
En tout cas, il y en a un que cette idylle
arrangerait au plus haut point.
C'est Mohamed Al-Fayed, le père de Dodi.
C'est d'ailleurs lui qui
a convoqué son fils sur le yacht,
pour qu'ils tiennent
compagnie à la princesse.
Soyons clairs, quel avenir
Dodi et Diana peuvent-ils espérer ?
Eux-mêmes vont aller chercher la réponse
auprès d'une voyante.
12 août 1997,
alors qu'ils se trouvent à Londres,
Dodi et Diana se rendent en hélicoptère jusqu'à
Lower Pilsley dans le nord de l'Angleterre,
Objet de ce discret déplacement :
Rendre visite à la voyante
attitrée de la princesse,
une certaine Rita Rogers.
Diana, depuis longtemps, ne fait plus
mystère de sa prédilection pour les médiums.
Or, vous allez le voir, c'est une
incroyable vision qu'elle leur livre.
Alors qu'elle se concentre sur Dodi,
Rita est assaillie
par des images sombres,
une voiture noire,
un tunnel près de l'eau
quelque part en France.
Des éléments qui font froid dans le dos,
au vu du drame qui va se dérouler
dans à peine trois semaines.
Mais l'heure n'est pas aux pressentiments.
Diana et Dodi s'envolent une dernière fois
pour une seconde croisière sur le Jonikal,
afin de profiter de la fin de l'été.
Le couple ne se cache presque plus.
La princesse aimait bien Dodi parce qu'il
était gentil avec elle,
et peu d'hommes l'avaient été par le passé.
Il était attentionné, c'était un gentleman.
Il lui disait qu'elle était belle,
et ça lui plaisait parce que Charles
n'avait jamais été comme ça avec elle.
Il pouvait être son Aristote Onassis
et elle Jackie Kennedy.
Pour Diana, ce sont les derniers
instants de bonheur.
Samedi 30 août, 13h30,
le jet privé des Al-Fayed
aux couleurs de Harrods,
quitte l'aéroport d'Olbia en Sardaigne,
direction Paris,
pour ce qui devrait n'être
qu'une simple escale.
La princesse veut être de retour
à Londres le lundi,
pour la rentrée scolaire
des jeunes Princes.
Seulement, l'escapade amoureuse
va virer au cauchemar.
16h, après avoir atterri
à l'aéroport du Bourget,
le couple arrive à la lisière
du bois de Boulogne,
pour une visite à l'ancienne
résidence du Duc de Windsor.
Ce roi d'Angleterre,
qui avait renoncé à la couronne,
pour épouser une Américaine divorcée,
Wallis Simpson.
Un autre couple scandaleux
pour Buckingham Palace.
Depuis la mort de Wallis, la somptueuse
demeure et louée par Mohamed Al-Fayed,
encore lui.
Manœuvre maladroite pour
se rapprocher de la famille royale.
Al-Fayed a investi pas moins
de 50 millionsde dollars,
dans la restauration
de l'hôtel particulier.
Mais en 1997,
furieux de n'avoir toujours pas été
considéré par la famille royale,
il a décidé de mettre en vente tout
le contenu de l'hôtel particulier.
Diana a-t-elle prévu
de se réserver quelques souvenirs ?
Le couple, en tout cas, ne s'attarde pas.
16h34, Dodi et Diana rejoignent
le Ritz, place Vendôme.
Les photographes qui les suivent
depuis Le Bourget,
les attendent déjà face
à l'entrée principale.
Alors ils décident de se faufiler
dans l'hôtel par l'entrée secondaire.
La journée a commencé aux aurores.
Il est temps pour le couple de prendre
un peu de repos dans la suite impériale,
réservée à la famille Al-Fayed.
1h plus tard,
Dodi quitte le palace pour
se rendre chez le joaillier Repossi,
de l'autre côté de la place Vendôme,
Place, que les photographes
n'ont pas l'intention de quitter.
Il laisse donc Diana s'adonner
à son passe temps favori,
téléphoner afin d'aller
récupérer chez le joaillier une bague.
S'agit-il, comme on le dira souvent,
d'une bague de fiançailles ?
Les proches de Diana
réfutent cette possibilité.
On avait une blague entre nous parce qu'il
lui avait offert des boucles d'oreilles,
un collier, un bracelet et une montre.
Et je lui ai dit : "Vous savez ce qui va
arriver ? Attention, ce sera une bague."
Et elle m'a dit :
"Non, non, il m'offrira pas de bague."
"Si il pourrait. Et s'il vous
en offre une, que ferez vous ?"
"Qu'est-ce que je ferais ?"
Je lui ai dit : "Vous n'avez qu'à la porter
à la main droite comme signe d'amitié."
19h,
le couple quitte le Ritz
pour l'appartement des Al-Fayed,
à l'angle des Champs-Elysées
et de la rue Arsene Houssaye.
Un grand dix pièces,
qui sert de pied à terre
à Dodi quand il est à Paris.
Dodi et Diana avaient prévu de dîner
dans un restaurant du Marais.
Ils sont donc venus ici
pour se préparer.
Mais la présence,
la pression des photographes,
se font envahissantes et les amènent
à modifier leurs plans.
Renonçant à leur dîner, ils font le choix
de regagner le Ritz, plus protecteur.
21h53,
Diana et Dodi reviennent place Vendôme.
Les photographes sont tenaces et ils forment
le plus exaspérant des comités d'accueil.
Si Diana paraît en prendre son parti,
il faut dire qu'elle est très habituée.
Dodi, lui, se montre énervé,
irrité par cette présence constante,
des chasseurs de photos.
21h54 le couple entre à l'Espadon,
le restaurant du Ritz,
Pour en ressortir
à peine dix minutes plus tard.
Car même là, Dodi et Diana
n'échappent pas aux regards indiscrets.
C'est donc finalement dans leur suite
qu'ils montent prendre leur dîner.
C'est alors qu'Henri Paul, le chef
de la sécurité du Ritz, regagne l'hôtel.
Il n'était plus de service, mais il a
été averti du retour imprévu du couple.
En attendant la suite des événements,
il commence par patienter au bar.
A-t-il bu ?
Pendant ce temps, une foule de plus
en plus dense s'est amassée sur la place.
Badauds et photographes attendent fébrilement
la sortie du couple qui finit de dîner.
De quoi agacer Dodi un peu plus.
Il décide alors une nouvelle fois
de bousculer les projets.
Il veut quitter discrètement le Ritz,
et pour cela,
met sur pied un petit stratagème.
Dodi voudrait repartir le plus vite possible
et furtivement rue Arsène Houssaye,
afin d'y passer la nuit.
Dites vous bien qu'il n'est pas habitué
du tout à tout ce harcèlement,
et qu'il est obsédé par sa sécurité.
Alors il se dit que l'appartement sera plus sûr,
plus intime que le Ritz.
Pour leurrer les photographes impatients,
électrisés, qui font le pied de grue,
devant le Palace depuis de longues heures,
il met au point un petit stratagème.
Sa voiture habituelle, accompagnée
par le véhicule de protection,
quittera ostensiblement le Ritz.
Pendant ce temps,
avec Diana et le garde du corps,
il s'éclipsera par la sortie annexe
à bord d'une autre voiture.
Cette seconde voiture,
il en confie le volant à Henri-Paul,
qui est son homme de confiance
lorsqu'il est à Paris.
Le moins que l'on puisse dire,
c'est que cette stratégie
n'est pas bien pensée.
Les règles de sécurité élémentaires
n'ont pas été respectées.
Les paparazzis qui attendent sur la place,
verront bien que les voitures sont vides.
Et surtout, la sortie par la rue Cambon
est connue des photographes.
D'ailleurs, certains s'y sont
déjà installés en attendant le couple.
Au cas où.
Mais que voulez vous,
Dodi Al-Fayed est le patron,
son plan est exécuté.
00h12, les caméras de sécurité
qui se trouvent,
au dessus de l'entrée
secondaire du Palace,
filment Diana, Dodi, Trevor Rees-Jones,
le garde du corps,
et Henri-Paul qui attendent que leur
soit amenée la voiture.
Ce sont les dernières
images de Diana en vie.
Treize courtes minutes avant le drame.
Devant l'hôtel, le leurre est en place.
00h19, la Mercedes arrive rue Cambon.
Les quatre passagers
s'y engouffrent rapidement.
Dodi et Diana songent-ils en cet instant
à la vision de la voyante anglaise ?
Probablement pas.
La voiture s'élance en direction
de la place de la Concorde,
suivi par quelques photographes à moto qui
ont bien l'intention de la prendre en chasse.
Ils sont là, déjà, frôlant les portières.
À la Concorde,
dès que le feu passe au vert,
Henri-Paul démarre en trombe,
et afin de pouvoir rouler vite,
prend la direction des quais de Seine.
Eric Falandry empruntait alors
le même trajet que la voiture.
Il a gardé des souvenirs
précis de cette nuit là,
souvenirs qu'il a accepté de nous confier.
Je me trouvais dans la descente
en train de double un taxi.
Je me rappelle que c'était une 406 blanche.
Quelqu'un arrive derrière moi assez vite,
Il colle ma voiture,
donc je dégage pour le laisser passer.
Je vois que c'est une Mercedes noire
qui roulait vraiment très vite.
Je remarque une femme assise
de trois quarts sur le côté comme ça,
qui tourne la tête en me regardant.
00h23, la voiture amorce la descente
du tunnel de l'Alma.
Pleine vitesse.
C'est là que soudain, Henri-Paul
se met à freiner lourdement sur 19 mètres.
La voiture heurte
une première fois le parapet.
Le chauffeur accélère de plus belle,
espérant redresser le véhicule.
Trop tard, la voiture vient s'encastrer
dans le 13ᵉ pilier.
Il est 0h25.
Dans le tunnel,
j'entends une double explosion.
Et en contrebas, je vois la Mercedes
à l'envers, en sens inverse.
Phares allumés.
Sous la violence de l'impact,
la Mercedes a fait un tête à queue,
et se retrouve immobilisée à contre sens.
De l'autre côté du tunnel, une voiture de SOS
médecin qui passait là par hasard s'arrête.
Le docteur Frédéric Mailliez en descend.
Il est la toute première personne
sur les lieux de l'accident.
Manifestement, il y a déjà deux passagers qui
sont morts, qui sont en état de mort apparente,
qui ne respirent plus
et qui ne réagissent plus.
C'est le conducteur et le passager arrière.
Seul Diana et le garde du corps
semblent encore en vie.
Je vois la première personne,
c'était le garde du corps qui avait,
la main sur le tableau de bord
et la tête en sang.
La jeune femme était assise ou accroupie sur
le sol à l'intérieur de la voiture, à l'arrière.
Elle n'avait pas de lésions
visibles importantes.
Elle semblait inanimée et quand
il lui a pris le poignet,
elle a entrouvert les yeux.
Je me rappelle. J'ai cette vision qui
m'a rassurée parce que je me suis dit,
Au moins, elle est vivante.
Assez vite des badauds
et les quelques photographes,
qui s'étaient fait distancer un peu avant
entourent la scène.
Il y avait des flashes qui crépitaient
dans tous les sens.
En aucun cas ils m'ont gêné pour porter
assistance aux victimes. Mais bon, ils étaient là.
Il y en a qui criait :
"Pas de photos de l'intérieur !"
Je ne savais pas qui c'était.
00h40, les premiers secours arrivent sur les
lieux et prennent le relais de l'urgentiste.
Pendant ce temps, la nouvelle se propage
parmi les services officiels.
Le préfet de police, appelé sur place,
prévient le ministre de l'Intérieur,
Jean-Pierre Chevènement.
Celui-ci fait informer l'ambassadeur
de Grande-Bretagne en France,
Michael Jay.
C'est lui qui représente les autorités
britanniques ce soir là.
Pour nous, il a accepté pour la première
fois de confier ses souvenirs.
C'était une surprise totale.
Ce coup de téléphone
a été une surprise totale.
On ne savait pas qu'elle était à Paris.
C'était l'un de ces moments dans une vie,
ou quelque chose auquel vous n'êtes
absolument pas préparé vous arrive.
Et vous faites de votre mieux
pour réagir comme il faut.
C'est l'hôpital de la Salpêtrière
qui est de garde cette nuit là.
Autrement dit, les meilleurs spécialistes
s'y trouvent pour d'éventuels accidents graves.
C'est là qu'est dirigée l'ambulance
qui transporte Diana.
Avant son arrivée, tout est mis en œuvre
pour sécuriser les lieux.
Mission que l'on confie au policier
Daniel Bourdon et à son équipe.
Ma mission incombe à une seule chose, Diana.
C'est à dire que trois de mes hommes
descendent au bloc opératoire,
et on me demande simplement
de sécuriser un petit carré,
et on me dit :
"Voilà, personne ne rentre."
Tout ce qu'il avait peur,
c'était de la photo volée.
Ce n'était pas qu'on incombe à sa vie,
c'était surtout la photo volée.
Rapidement, ce qui ressemble
à une cellule de crise,
est mis en place à l'hôpital.
Quand on est arrivé à l'hôpital, on nous
a dit que la princesse avait été blessée,
mais personne ne savait
si sa vie était en danger.
On a été accueillis par Jean-Pierre
Chevènement qui nous a emmenés dans une pièce,
où on a pu commencer à téléphoner
à Balmoral, à Downing Street,
pour informer le prince et le Premier ministre
de ce qu'il se passait.
1h45, l'ambulance,
80 minutes après l'accident,
arrive sur le pont d'Austerlitz,
à seulement 600 mètres de l'hôpital.
Ce qui me choque,
c'est la lenteur à laquelle elle va.
Elle va même pas au pas.
Elle fait quelques mètres, elle s'arrête,
quelques mètres, elle s'arrête.
Elle met plus de 20 minutes à arriver.
Mais en fait, ce que j'apprends plus tard,
c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'ils arrêtent,
c'est parce que le cœur s'arrête.
Et il redémarre à chaque fois.
2h12,
l'ambulance atteint enfin l'hôpital.
Rien ne filtre de l'état de santé
précis de la princesse,
qui est envoyée d'urgence au bloc.
Le temps paraît maintenant suspendu.
On voit sortir d'abord un brancard
et on pense que c'est elle.
mais c'est le garde du corps qui sort
qui lui a été opéré.
Il a vraiment, au niveau facial,
tout a été brisé.
On pense que c'est elle.
On se dit ça y est, c'est fini.
Non, pas du tout, elle est toujours
en salle d'opération.
Vers 4h du matin, un petit peu avant,
je vois les médecins
ressortirent la tête basse.
Et là, tout de suite,
ça me fait tilt.
Il est 4h du matin.
La princesse de Galles vient de mourir.
Cette nuit, la princesse de Galles
a été victime à Paris.
d'un accident de la circulation
à grande vitesse.
Une thoracotomie  d'urgence a mis
en évidence une plaie importante,
de la veine pulmonaire gauche.
Malgré la fermeture de cette plaie,
et un massage cardiaque
externe et interne de 2h,
aucune efficacité circulatoire
n'a pu être rétablie,
et le décès a été constaté à 4h du matin.
C'était impossible de ne pas être ému.
C'était un moment extraordinairement
difficile et émouvant.
L'accident de ce soir
est une terrible tragédie.
Le décès de la princesse de Galles nous
emplit tous d'une grande douleur,
et d'un profond chagrin.
La princesse de Galles était
une personnalité si extraordinaire,
populaire, magnétique,
que j'ai réalisé que la nouvelle
de sa mort allait provoquer,
des réactions totalement imprévisibles
dans le monde entier.
Pendant ce temps, le corps de Diana
est installé dans une chambre,
veillée par Daniel Bourdon.
Quand je rentre dans l'ascenseur,
je prends un peu de place,
je bouge légèrement le drap,
et on voit apparaître un bout de sa jambe.
C'est impressionnant de voir
la princesse comme ça.
Et j'ai remis tout de suite le drap.
Et avec l'infirmière,
on se dit c'est quand même incroyable,
d'avoir Diana là, décédée.
C'était vraiment dommage.
On était vraiment déçus.
Bonjour, l'information ce matin
provoque une véritable onde de choc,
et une très vive émotion.
Lady Diana est morte...
Alors que Paris s'éveille,
Seuls quelques officiels
et quelques proches,
sont autorisés à se rendre au chevet
de la princesse défunte.
Les fenêtres étaient ouvertes,
il y avait un ventilateur dans la chambre,
et la princesse
était allongée sur un lit.
Je me suis approché
et je pouvais voir ses cheveux,
et ses cils bouger
à cause du ventilateur.
Je l'ai regardé et je lui ai dit :
"Allez, ouvrez les yeux.
Ouvrez les yeux."
J'ai soudain réalisé
qu'elle n'était plus là.
Alors je me suis rappelé quelque
chose qu'elle m'avait raconté.
Elle m'a dit un jour que
le plus beau moment de sa vie,
avait été d'accompagner
quelqu'un qui venait de mourir.
Elle lui tenait la main,
elle a senti qu'il s'en allait,
Et elle m'a dit : "Savez-vous
ce qu'il se passe à ce moment précis ?
Votre esprit s'échappe de votre corps,
mais il reste un instant
dans la pièce et il regarde.
Alors je savais qu'elle était là,
avec moi.
Et c'est là que j'ai laissé
mes émotions me submerger.
Au même moment, devant l'hôpital,
une foule d'anonymes rend
déjà hommage à la princesse.
Mais l'émotion ne tarde pas à faire place aux
premières interrogations,
sur les causes du drame.
Il est facile d'imaginer l'embarras
des autorités de l'époque,
face à la disparition si brutale,
d'une personnalité
au statut des plus ambiguës.
Certes, Diana était
divorcée du prince Charles,
mais elle demeurait en titre
La Princesse de Galles.
Le drame s'est produit
en plein cœur de la capitale.
Pour les autorités françaises, on est à
l'époque de la cohabitation Chirac-Jospin,
le dossier est épineux, il faut le traiter
avec autant de discrétion que d'efficacité.
Quant aux autorités britanniques,
c'est encore plus délicat pour elles.
La mort de Diana pose de graves questions.
Vous vous rappelez peut-être le film The
Queen du réalisateur Stephen Frears.
Il raconte l'extraordinaire bras de fer,
entre la reine Elizabeth
et son Premier ministre Tony Blair,
quant à l'attitude à adopter
par la Couronne.
Faut-il ou non organiser
des obsèques nationales ?
Je crois qu'il n'est pas excessif de dire que,
pendant quelques jours au moins,
la monarchie anglaise
a vacillé sur ses bases.
Au petit matin du 31 août,
l'émotion populaire en France,
au Royaume-Uni,
dans le Commonwealth
et plus généralement dans le monde,
est quasi sans précédent.
Chacun se rappelle l'endroit où il était
quand il a appris la nouvelle,
à la télé ou à la radio.
Et l'effet que ça a eu.
C'était une surprise.
Un choc. Vraiment.
Tony Blair dira : "Les gens partout
avaient foi en la princesse Diana.
C'était la princesse du peuple."
Petite gens est déshéritée,
la pleure de façon quasi unanime.
Un paradoxe lorsqu'on sait quelle vie elle
menait dans les derniers mois de son existence.
Mais à l'émotion se mêle la colère.
Quelques heures après le drame, le propre
frère de Diana, Lord Charles Spencer,
désigne ainsi ceux
qu'il considère comme coupables.
Ce n'est pas le temps des accusations,
mais celui de la tristesse.
Je dirais cependant que j'ai toujours
pensé que la presse finirait par la tuer.
Mais même moi, je ne pensais pas qu'elle
aurait une responsabilité,
aussi directe dans sa mort.
Il me semble que tous les patrons de presse,
toutes les publications,
qui ont payé pour des photographies, qui ont
encouragé des individus cupides et impitoyable,
à tout risqué pour une image de Diana,
ont aujourd'hui du sang sur les mains.
Coupables les photographes, mais de quoi ?
Que s'est-il vraiment passé
sous le tunnel de l'Alma ?
A Paris, l'enquête hautement explosive,
s'est ouverte immédiatement,
en pleine nuit.
Elle a été confiée à la brigade criminelle
alors dirigée par Martine Monteil.
A priori, c'est un accident de voie publique.
Ce n'est pas tout à fait pour la crim
mais d'un autre côté, je comprends,
Eu égard à la personnalité surtout
de la victime Princesse de Galles,
que ça va être un événement
et qu'il va falloir jouer serré,
et faire un travail considérable.
C'est Jean-Claude Mulès, chef procédurier,
qui a été chargé de l'enquête.
Vu la pression qui fut sur nous,
cette pression énorme.
On a essayé d'éliminer toutes
les hypothèses farfelues,
et autres qui ont existé.
Et Dieu sait s'il y en a eu.
De tous bords,
de tous les pays.
Et il fallait les dégonfler.
Il fallait les éliminer une par une.
Et pour ce faire,
on passe son temps à démontrer qu'il n'y
a pas eu qu'à prouver qu'il y a eu.
Pourquoi le chauffeur a-t-il soudain
freiné à l'entrée du tunnel ?
A-t-il cherché à éviter un obstacle ?
A-t-il été gêné par des photographes ?
Dès 00h40 ce 31 août, 6 d'entre eux
et un motard de presse,
ont été mis en garde à vue.
Le fourgon quittait tout juste la Seine,
au moment où Pierre Roussel,
à l'époque photo reporter,
arrivait sur les lieux
pour couvrir l'accident.
Il est intéressant de noter la sociologie
des photographes qui ont été,
arrêtés par la police. Et parmi eux,
il y a un très bon photographe.
Il dira :
"Je me suis senti extrêmement mal à l'aise."
Il y a un jeune qui
va essayer d'ouvrir la porte,
de parler en anglais à la princesse
qui est mourante.
Il y en a d'autres qui sont
plus dans une logique de paparazzade pure.
En fait, on se rend compte
qu'on a là différentes réactions,
parce que le profil
des photographes est différent.
1, ils devaient dire quel était leur rôle,
est-ce qu'ils avaient vraiment
un peu trop chassé cette voiture ?
Deuxièmement, quel était leur rôle à l'arrivée ?
Ont ils appelé les secours...
Et puis troisièmement, quid des photos.
Il n'était pas question de laisser partir,
comme ça dans le monde entier des photos,
qui relèvent de la plus grande intimité.
Et pour cause.
Les photos sont saisies et les témoignages
des photographes recueillis minutieusement.
Presque aussitôt, d'autres pistes émergent.
Certains affirment que la Mercedes,
en entrant dans le tunnel,
aurait dépassé une voiture
de couleur sombre.
D'autres mentionnent
la présence d'une moto.
Seulement, l'analyse scientifique
de la voiture accidentée,
révèle des traces de peinture blanche.
Elles proviennent d'une Fiat Uno.
La Mercedes l'aurait elle heurté
avant de s'écraser contre le pilier ?
Au fil des jours, cette Fiat Uno va
devenir l'élément fantôme de l'enquête,
car ni elle ni son conducteur
n'ont jamais pu être retrouvé.
Un témoin a bien relaté
qu'il avait vu cette fiat Uno,
parce que lui, ce témoin,
il arrivait par le haut,
et la fiat Uno sortait du tunnel
et il a vu sortir du tunnel une Fiat Uno,
qui roulait très lentement avec un gars
qui regardait dans son rétroviseur,
comme tétanisé.
Cet homme là, s'il avait été interpellé,
Identifié et interpellé, serait devenu,
aux yeux du grand public
le tueur de princesse.
Alors qu'il n'était peut-être qu'un seul
témoin, disons, d'un accident.
Il a dû avoir une peur monstrueuse
pour différentes raisons.
1,
c'est un monsieur qui ne devait
pas être à Paris à ce moment là,
Donc il n'avait pas intérêt
à le faire savoir.
Peut-être quelqu'un en situation
irrégulière,
peut-être quelqu'un de recherché.
Et lui, il a du... Il a tiré droit...
Une autre piste se concentre sur le
chauffeur, le fameux Henri-Paul,
dont on effectue l'autopsie
avec prise de sang.
D'après les résultats de l'analyse
de sang, 1 gramme 74.
Déjà quelqu'un qui a bu quelque chose,
il y a une réaction dans le sang,
ça n'est pas quelqu'un qui titube,
qui est ivre,
d'ailleurs la voiture traçait droit
tout le reste de l'itinéraire.
La chose qui est un petit peu plus gênante,
c'est qu'on se rend compte,
que dans les analyses, il y a des traces
de noctamide et de Prozac je crois,
enfin un produit de ce type.
Des tranquillisants associés à de l'alcool,
Henri-paul serait donc
le principal responsable.
Problème, ses parents et son employeur,
Mohamed Al-Fayed,
réfute en bloc ses analyses.
Le père de Dodi a une autre théorie.
Le couple, selon lui, aurait été assassiné
par les services britanniques.
Pas question pour la monarchie
d'accepter que la mère du futur roi,
vive avec un Égyptien musulman.
Il n'empêche, l'enquête française conclut
à un accident due à la vitesse élevée,
100 km/h. À l'accrochage présumé
avec une Fiat tous nos blanches,
mais aussi à l'état d'ébriété d'Henri-Paul,
le tout conjugué à la pression des photographes,
atteignant son paroxysme.
Il y a une convergence qui s'est faite
entre ces différents éléments,
et qui a conduit au drame.
Est-ce que les photographes
font partie de cette boucle ?
La réponse est clairement oui.
Est-ce que les photographes sont
responsables de ce qui s'est passé ?
La réponse est clairement non.
Les photographes seront blanchis,
distancés par la Mercedes au niveau
de la place de la Concorde,
ils n'ont pas pu être
la cause directe de l'accident.
Il n'empêche, l'attitude collective de ceux
qui font la presse people pose question.
De ceux qui la font
et de ceux qui la lisent.
En 1997, ce drame est un électrochoc
pour tout le monde.
Lecteurs de la presse people, éditeurs,
photographes, annonceurs.
Et à ce moment là,
tout le monde est dans...
"Plus jamais ça !"
Quand je vois ce qu'est la presse people
italienne, quand je vois le traitement,
photographique qui est réservé à
Kate Middleton, épouse de William,
fils de Diana,
Quand je vois aujourd'hui ce qu'est une course
poursuite dans les rues de Los Angeles,
derrière Rihanna, derrière Beyoncé,
est-ce que j'ai le sentiment que
les leçons de 1997 ont été retenues ?
Non.
Malgré les conclusions de l'enquête, des
rumeurs d assassinat émergent régulièrement.
Aux yeux du public, le simple fait qu'on
saisisse la brigade criminelle,
induisait qu'il y avait, de façon
sous jacente, peut-être un crime.
Et ça dénaturait complètement l'approche
journalistique et de l'opinion publique.
Notre princesse de conte de fées ne meurt
pas dans un banal accident d'alcoolique,
sous un tunnel un samedi soir.
C'est l'une des raisons qui explique que tant
de théories du complot aient émergé si vite.
Les gens n'arrivaient pas à associer l'image
idéale qu'ils avaient de la princesse de Galles,
à la façon si banale
dont elle a perdu la vie.
C'était trop difficile à accepter
pour beaucoup de gens.
Les Anglais, sous le choc, s'interrogent :
"Où est notre reine ?"
Pendant les quelques jours
qui suivent le crash,
à Balmoral, en Écosse,
la reine ne s'exprime pas.
Un silence assourdissant comparé
à l'émotion qui embrase tout son peuple.
Il faudra attendre cinq jours
pour qu'Elisabeth revienne à Londres.
Elle s'exprime alors à la télévision,
chose rarissime devant
26 millions de personnes.
Ce que je vous dis aujourd'hui,
en tant que reine,
et en tant que grand-mère,
je le dis du fond de mon cœur,
D'abord, je veux rendre hommage
à Diana personnellement,
C'était un être humain
doué et exceptionnel,
Dans les bons moments
comme dans les mauvais,
elle n'a jamais perdu sa capacité
de sourire et de rire,
ni celle d'inspirer les autres
avec sa chaleur et sa gentillesse.
Le lendemain, samedi 6 septembre,
3 millions de personnes, à Londres,
suivent les funérailles
de la Princesse des Cœurs.
Des centaines de millions sont
devant leur poste de télévision.
Le monde entier, j'ai l'impression,
a eu un sentiment d'injustice,
et de malheur à ce moment là.
Je crois qu'on a, pendant
ces funérailles, on a partagé,
une émotion commune.
C'était un moment incroyable
de notre histoire.
L'événement le plus regardé de l'histoire.
Mais qui était cette femme ?
Finalement, très peu de gens
savaient qui elle était.
Et à quel point elle était
entière et vraie.
Loin de la foule,
la princesse de Galles
sera inhumée sur une île,
au milieu d'un lac à Althorp,
dans la propriété des Spencer,
où elle avait passé toute son enfance.
J'ai évoqué les soupçons qui pesaient
sur la mort de Diana et de son compagnon.
Mais disons le, aucun élément
n'a pu à ce jour,
étayer les différentes thèses
en faveur de l'assassinat.
Ce qui est certain, c'est que
le couple star de l'été 97,
réunissait contre lui beaucoup d'ennemis,
et que même s'il ne s'agit
que d'un accident,
certains, en l'apprenant,
ont dû souffler,
et se frotter les mains.